[Music]
in YouTube drama news I'm just gonna
have to close my mouth this hall video
submitted by Gerald from Singapore hello
top YouTube creators are calling out to
five media for shady practices oh we
don't both take it away Moses we don't
need a freeway little reading for those
who are not in the loop of YouTube but
watched only JK mhm
we could give them a little rundown on
[Music]
define media is the company that
purchased Smosh like 10 like eight years
ago like something like that a long time
ago right so they bought Smosh and are
you wearing a ski mask yes
it's not even a beanie yes a schema yeah
I'm focused I gotta hear completely um I
mean it's a sick huh so you know but so
they bought Smosh and i'ma tell y'all
this because Anthony Padilla said in his
video apparently they sold Smosh for
zero dollars you know and only four
stocks in the company which were useless
because the company never went public he
[ __ ] up so bad I mean they were young
though they were like 80 on that I just
heard that in Antep well yeah I saw the
same video he really sold it for zero
dollars no no he sold it for stock
mm-hmm so the thing is when he sold defi
he's sold Smosh for stock hoping that a
bigger company can one day blow it up
and sell it because it's beyond his
ability but he was hella young yeah
that's right that's what I mean they
sold it for you roll dollars and spa
I just couldn't believe but but but they
didn't know anything about business in
this video to summarize it he didn't
know anything about business he was
really young this was his first time he
got taken advantage of and so basically
he did what he did but there was a lot
of stuff where he couldn't talk about so
it was easier for him to leave Smosh
remembered that way several years ago
yeah what happened well alright so I'm
gonna give you a little bit background
Smosh like I'm part of Smosh games those
either didn't know but Smosh games and
Smosh still make millions of dollars
every year I mean the Adsense is crazy
we have over like 8000 monetized videos
so the retrograde views bring in crazy
Adsense
there's everything's loaded up with ads
we get like a lot of brand deals we're
on Amazon Prime I mean it still makes
millions of dollars but défi invested in
a few smaller business practices that
didn't exactly give returns so there was
a lot of dead channels and dead arms in
the company and the two brands clever
who was like our beauty and like makeup
thing and then Smosh we're keeping the
lights on so you guys were subsidizing a
lot of other challenge yeah it's
basically and they are in my opinion I
feel like they made some poor real
estate practices we had two offices in
Beverly Hills
we had one office in Times Square we
also had offices in San Francisco
Chicago yeah they were really and I
heard that the New York office has
custom wallpapers in every room like
each person if they had their office
they could just customize their
wallpaper so they were just and like I
get it I think part of the thing is like
to for them to be taken very seriously
so that like more people spend money but
that's not what happened so like two
weeks ago on Friday we all all and like
let me let y'all know right now I was in
a livestream when this happened this is
the actual tea this is the actual tea so
I'm in a lot Rula girl with two of my
co-workers and we get an email from the
CEO named Matt diamond who like that's
one of those weird shady people that you
never see man
man diamond since that an email at 1:55
and says everyone dial in company called
meeting in 25 minutes when the CEO is a
mass email to everyone and says company
called now I'm on a live stream right
that sounds serious
as well and there's three of us in the
room and we're joking we're like oh is
it finally happening is it there's 30
minutes of footage online of me Tim and
my friend taught me finding out we're
losing our job we had to keep stringing
so we'll say we get that email right so
we're like word what the [ __ ] but we
know that Smosh makes so much money so
like we're chilling you know like we're
like okay alright well we'll see so we
get the they get on the call we can't
get on the call cuz we're doing the live
stream so we're texting somebody on the
other side of the office and they're in
the call and basically he says the
company will cease operations on January
2nd we're like I don't know all the
details of it but basically that like
with them information we got back during
the live stream was everyone's getting
laid off on January 2nd just out of
[ __ ] nowhere right and so we're like
word so we finished the live stream when
we got there and everyone's standing out
there like what just happened you know
crazy right so like over the weekend
everyone's kind of like a little sad
just point but they say like we're still
gonna be getting paychecks and stuff
like that for the next two months so
Tuesday rolls
oh no Tuesday rolls around and he gave
everyone like a two-month heads-up yeah
well they were required by law because
of something called the Warren Act if a
plant or a facility shuts down they must
give the workers two months notice Oh
Tuesday rolls around and we get an email
that says this is an update the layoff
will be effective immediately as of
November 6 so they are like your health
care lasts until the end of the month
and they cut off all payments so on so
defy like financially [ __ ] us all over
board like they go from saying you'll be
getting like you know ten thousand
twelve thousand dollars in the next few
months - you get nothing but your health
insurance is over on November 30th so
like that's literally what happened to
[ __ ] everybody and I'm
on the side of the channel that still
make it Bank right so that's bad enough
come to find out I like your voice level
changes by though it's very exciting
this whole video is Bo's talking for 14
minutes tree but yeah it's so like that
T so that that's bad enough
we're all processing because what the
[ __ ] just happened you know and so but
we're not we're down but we're not out
because Smosh is still very successful
and all another studio has to do is come
in and buy it you know like for money
this time yes for money for money
yeah we didn't know that the company had
started going over month a months ago
and they knew that and they were trying
to use Smosh to pay for everything and
they just couldn't keep up with it where
they should have crushed I've got some
other practices now the real [ __ ] up
thing that happened was the de 5 media
was an MCN and it owned multiple
channels they would email people like
they could have emailed JK news and said
hi where did this entity we own these
brands these brands these brands and
they would use Smosh and be like we own
Smosh we can blow your channel up and
they would purchase people's channels
outright and then the deal was that defy
takes all of their adsense and then they
take 7% and then cut them a check and
then send the adsense back to the people
right well they stopped paying people in
September they stopped paying everyone
and they owned over a hundred and fifty
channel they stopped paying everyone
September first and then they shut down
in November and they took all of that
money whoa step in and cut people from
the MCM so that people could get their
absence back but they're also like we
don't know what to tell you about those
last two months of pay and I saw Chad
wild clay tweeted that he had 421
million views that month that's like
eight hundred thousand dollars everyone
and use it to pay their debt and then
like I know Matt Pat's on the network
you know milkman
that's just the that's the oven but the
company has completely filed for
bankruptcy and dissolved
therefore nobody's liable when you file
a chapter 7 no feel stole money yeah
even if you're a bankrupt they could be
that guy can't that be punishable by law
because because they're only they're
only basically they're a pass-through so
when the money comes in and then they
take seven percent they're not supposed
to take a hundred percent or else that's
just stealing it is but that's the thing
when you file a chapter seven you're not
liable for anything even more and then
also the tier list as it goes right now
is if any money gets paid out one they
have to pay the investors first Smosh
got a seventy million dollar investment
last year so that takes priority then
second priority would be all the workers
that were laid off versus uh bushes us
so we're probably never getting paid for
those two months you better steal a
couple staplers right everything that
would be all of the people that got
their ads in stolen even for me Dawson's
boyfriend was on the network and so he
started tweeting out like started
tweeting out about it but then he
eventually started just being like
YouTube can you pay us back because they
know us all business baby and there's
nothing they can do there's a the five
media and alloy the same company yeah oh
I see yeah it was a like who's the main
head is it just Matt diamond diamond and
Keith Richmond office a lot all the time
so like for the widest names I've ever
heard in my life
[ __ ] crazy dude it's not like you
made that [ __ ] up on the spot Matt
diamond and uh Keith Richmond dude but
like you know a lot of people were
saying like Smosh is over and it's
really not it's just it's a process for
a new thing to buy it yeah basically
like the bank owns all the properties so
there's a giant the viewership is there
the audience is there yeah it's not that
the business shut down it's just the
financial part needs to get cleaned up
but someone will come and buy it yeah
for sure huh how much dude that's the
crazy thing I'm curious about you guys
got in your wallet why don't you guys
own Smosh on your own it's doing it
they're doing an auction the bank's
doing an auction for all the problems
YouTube auction
yes I was like I was like I'm trying to
get on that list I want to see what's
going on once why four to doo doo doo
she's gonna be [ __ ] Millions get you
nice Ted go buy it so we're still we're
still recording videos yeah there's a
there's one video that like the day that
we got that email that said like y'all
aren't even getting paid for the like
the rest of it we still had one more
video to shoot and we were like so why
we're not gonna do this right and they
were like we still have to shoot it why
it's still a video why they just they
said obligation you have to yeah I mean
cuz they'd already bull you're ready you
know you're already done like I mean
they still Bay and they like had already
let go of like post-production and stuff
so no one would even be there to edit it
so there's still like a video that they
made us do like after we knew everything
and we just had to ride through it
that's the T y'all and that's tough yeah
that legal [ __ ] is a whole nother beast
though I was the most fascinating 12
minute story of my watching everything
unfold dude for some reason I saw a
building explode not when they got
evicted from the office bruh this whole
company knew what they were doing they
did not pay rent on the first because
they knew what was up you know yeah yeah
what I'll tell you this I'll try to get
you on as many videos that JK as
possible still chillin dude she said
dude we had offices in Japan we got it
up in Tokyo's we had it up in China and
you could come work for JK but you know
what that is
they're like you know what they are
they're like a use luxury car it [ __ ]
depreciates like a [ __ ] it's all
flashed well depends what kind of luxury
1992 Toyota Camry okay yes
we got health care
we're very we're very dependable yes
soap so I need that water Kirkland
people I'll do a while educate but
that's gonna get 12 use why I left Jacob
you don't know where the opposite you
can't leave I was technically out late
they say lay off I say vacation you
gotta have a damn good reason to leave
JK except actually I did have I was in a
somebody twitch stream earlier today and
it was my friend stream and I were you
subscribed and I was like eh let me
throw my friend a sub and like when I
subbed it was like Big Boss Bo's to
subscribe and then somebody and the chat
was like aunt Big Boss Bo's I'm so sorry
about your job you can't afford this
take a selfie hey Bo's you don't need to
subscribe we know that you need the
money
yeah you don't have to put on airs for
us like take that three dollars back I'm
on vacation until further notice
[Music]